thunderhorse is fire auditor but forgot
again here we go
fifty-three entries 1819 and here we go
here we go okay game time clear your
head clear your head it's time for the
horse quit horsing around there should
be seven you've seen it you've seen it
once you'll see it again bond push pawn
push No
okay the bishop the bishop the bishop
pawn push I should have done it here we
go here we go here we go here we go here
we go go go go go go that bishop has to
get out of there get out of there bishop
he's got to go chop get a pond right
here
my bishop be scared be very scared
my king is gonna have to run for the
hills run for the hills King run this is
scary
run no no no anything but that I didn't
mean to do it was a mouse lip I promise
Oh
it was scary scary time scary time oh I
got a bishop for free I got a knight for
free Oh undermine this pawn Oh be scared
be very scared
Oh Oh crumbling it's crumbling crumbling
I'm in check discovered check I got a
pile looking for me mates I have this
covered my queen has it this is me or
something close to it
check check check check check sir for
everybody here we go pawn pusher oh I
got the Queen the queen is dead a cooked
Queen a new queen is on the scene back
to tournament a new queen on the scene -
- a lot
- in a few ones here who's this
oh the phantom rook variation here we go
here we go
III ninety-two d3 what's it gonna be
down on time and no rook no trades no
trades what's the scoop what's the scoop
G for my g3 no no trades no soup for you
f4 f5 g4 g5 you name it it's happening G
file no clothes keep it closed
the knight and the bishop are not able
to play now they're not able to play and
they don't like not being able to play I
need to get my queen here before the
Queen gets there actually my knight
could have done the job anyhow rook here
and get out of there clean you need to
go somewhere else she's gonna get
trapped if you go there you're trapped
you're trapped you have no business
being in my territory oh go and taking
somebody down
she's taking somebody down with her
let's go blow it open coming up
I really don't want to have to take with
the pawn but I'm gonna do it let's go
let's go let's roll here let's roll I'm
not okay I'm gonna oh I'm on the night
looking for made on h8 made Nha anywhere
but there the Knights gonna grab the
pond no it's not
let's come here the bishop is gonna go
to defend okay I got to go to h6 my
knight wants to be on h6
coming up night okay now the bishop has
to take and then it's me otherwise
there's killer discoveries right here
and then
year unavoidable no time back to
tournament six six six six six five five
five five four
I think I got along okay I didn't have
to read them all off you don't have to
do that all right
oh the four pawns
floor pawns attack oh this is a nice
setup how can I deal with this go this
way it'll never suspect that open it up
you know you want to open it up shut it
down I'm in trouble
Oh am I in trouble I have to hide behind
their pond somehow oh I'm dead no no no
I'm not I had the bishop I'm still dead
though they're gonna kill this guy
I'm a dead man I'm a dead man but how
much time do they have no time be scared
be very scared
check that pond needs to go
get out of there before it's too late
oh it's too late anyhow oh I want to cry
I want to cry the bots gonna push Oh is
there a way out stay here please just
stay put stay put
come on get this and then threaten made
on g2 oh I'm gonna get killed
oh I'm a dead man I'm a dead man
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead oh I could do
this I guess oh I'm so dead I'm so dead
there's no way you can recover from this
take it Knight and then move Knight is
there a way out I got to run like a
bandit run run come on you could do this
I'm getting mated I'm getting mated I'm
getting mated I made it tournament I'll
block your ears especially if things
aren't looking good on the board right
there I can't help it it just comes
right out of me I can't Oh what do you
can you do oh that floorpan I what can
you do
no no trades man come on this is the
Thunder Horse I look forward to the
Thunder was some trouble my King has to
run put on your running shoes King
get out of there bishop I can't okay
come on go over here over here's where
you want to be G to take my bishop take
them I'll go for a queen trade actually
well I got free Queen trade support them
oh oh oh
red alert dark squares dark squares dark
squares watch over them or you're dead
man you're dead man if you don't watch
over you dark squares actually I have
this pawn why didn't I take it that was
a free pawn okay I'll take it now Knight
right here coming up chop okay right
here forks forks forks everywhere
watch out for 9594 you know the screen
I'm trying to name stop it stop it right
now I have a fork why didn't I do that
let's get this guy my opponents down on
time things are looking pretty looking
pretty Bishop here check oh I should
check on the knight my Knights a machine
right there look at him sitting proud
pin Knight followed up with killer Oh
Bishop's cooked the cooked fish up I'm
actually winning this regardless of time
pawn push or am i oh I have to throw on
some checks that pounds fast run King
run check a ruski okay back to
tournament 22 points you can't catch 22
oh that there is actually some sense of
that one I just fell right into placed
in it okay let's go I'm glad there's no
four pawns attack that's actually
something that works well actually it
doesn't no I didn't mean to say that
case you're watching in case you're
listening no it actually doesn't work
well don't so don't do it where are you
gonna Castle King tell me your address
where are you gonna live
come on my Bishop wants to play he's
playing now that night that night needs
to go okay I see where the king is I'm
coming after you I'm hunting you down
I'm trying to break things up pins pins
everywhere guard the pond here we go
what's my King doing over here over here
again rook over okay right now let's go
b5 is the way to go out the night it
gets pinned if it goes there it gets
pinned it's a
in the classic pin and then wind trick
pin and then a winner pin a ruski
followed by a winner ooh ski oh the
queen is cooked cooked queen chopped it
up let's do this so the file doesn't the
a file doesn't open up but I guess the
other file opens up let's do this I want
the B file B file please I'm on the rook
and the bishop o with check I got the
rook my queens running wild she's
getting excited excited Queen mates if
the knight moves
Rippey eight
there's no way to chase the Queen away
oh that's me that was a quick one sort
of eighteen thirty four thirty um
dropping back okay I'm in ninth nineteen
and changed the assassin oh I had to
play this guy in um regular chess tough
games no I got a play without the old
Knight the OL night is long gone here
okay let's get this rolling here come on
I could do this you could do this no no
no no no no over here let's push let's
push again I can't push again I'm in a
pin I got a fork though I got some
material back material for me yes they
resigned back to tournament twenty-eight
thirty Six's top I have 28 let's go you
can do this come on double the points
double the points double the points and
what are we gonna have a non mover just
an odd mover he has 30 points he's gonna
move he's up there he's having a
fantastic tournament let's go I'm coming
at the king I'm coming at you my knight
needs to go on a little hike take a hike
tonight there you go you know you want
to be on c4 no keep it closed it's gonna
be broken open oh this is bad
oh really okay I got some material back
I can queenside castle he grabbed a rope
but I'm not gonna do that I can
do better right Oh pin pin that night
there you go
I got c4 as well no keep it closed that
Knight is dead he's a dead man
I could take him at any moment chase
this night away oh he's coming here take
this night before it's too late
take a look I guess mmm come over here
this nights gonna kill me this pound is
gonna kill me if I don't do something oh
man let's come here come on come on
me me me Oh something's happening it's
bad mate mate me that's me that's back
to turn it 48 42 41 40 don't count me
out yet I lost one but I'm coming down
with some acres hopefully I've no idea
what I'm saying when I play these games
it's a really a mystery to me when I
rewatched them oh I didn't mean to do
that
I didn't want to exchange I didn't want
to do that either okay I'm glad I most
slipped on that I didn't want to do that
the bishop could be cooked Michael my
king Esther run over here run for the
hills over here where it's safe it's
safe and sound over here pawn push I
push the knight around let's go over
here
push the knight push I push back if you
push me I'm gonna push back push here
push push that's the plan
forks coming up Knight f4 juicy squares
my queen wants to be on b3 oh right here
is a this is a bad man right here a very
very bad man that night okay this is a
good square for my night this night has
to go you got a go Knight can't deal
with you oh oh I got that one
oh there rook is silly silly rook I can
actually trade I have material oh I got
the Queen
the ladies gun the bishops gun the King
is cooked oh this is deadly the bishops
coming to life deadly discovered checks
you name it it's happening discovered
checkland chop-chop-chop severy where me
soon me this is me back determined had
me in the corner back determinate 64 56
54 54 did i name those numbers right
let's go here let's go what are you
saying
yes that's what I'm saying right there
sixty four sixty two quick resign errs
quick resign errs Leon Oh Leon is gonna
give me a beating without the bishop ons
I have nothing or do i oh oh
sneaky sneaky check uh-oh be very scared
be very scared
check come on go here go here yes I got
the Queenie the queen is dead chop job
kill a night castle develop save it
trade Bishop's I'm gonna take the night
get rid of the glue the night is the
glue dodge check rip through here oh I
didn't want to do that the bishops gonna
this is this is a strong Bishop okay I'm
gonna grab a pawn first and then um
let's do that he's important to me he's
an important guy over there and okay now
this is a bit of a pain right here let's
go oh are you kidding me oh now I have
this okay let's give a check just for
fun check again
grab now and then this and then okay can
give a check
oh this isn't me no no way oh whoa that
was really close to me wow that was
really close to me come on this is me
back to tournament
back to tournament what do we got 80 to
80
I'm right up there nap don't count me
out nap
who's this I thought it was Bruce Lee
for some reason I read that as Bruce Lee
okay I'm all right with this set up that
White's gonna run with g5 can I make
that happen and make that happen
f5 I want to maybe get f5 in and then
g5f ig5 am i waiting some material ok
let's get this in them get that night
away come inside Castle pawn push that
Knight needs to get out of there what am
i doing am i doing okay here we go
not here or something oh my bishop has
to back up let's keep it closed over
here pod push I should have done palm
push uh push now I guess are they gonna
open that stuff up I'm gonna take care
and then here that pawns gonna fall
let's get over here okay what do we got
what do we have here check I got the
rook I got umm what do I have my rook is
gonna be hit that's a good move let's
come here I'm on the rook and I should
have what am i doing what am i doing
stop the knight i can swap the puns just
gonna push and my bishop looks stupid
okay actually Brooke I should have done
work here
there's bishop check as well okay
there's got to be stuff there's got to
be stuff Queen here mate threat is it
unavoidable are you kidding me is this
unavoidable whoa are you kidding me
look at those bishops they're sitting
proud right there is this me woah this
is me Oh deadly pins 110 100 - 100 okay
there's two ahead of me 11 and changed
oh this guy has the 110 I'm out one pun
but it's the F pun I have a half-open F
file get out of there Knight I have the
F file open up pinpointing their file
right here could hit me hit three times
it's hit three
defended just twice get out of there
night do I have this f6 I'm gonna get to
f6
Oh drop the material let's get back over
here get back over here man
got to get that bishop I have the bishop
at least dark-squared bishop is mine
he's all mine let's go here back up
what's the what's the count what is the
count here I got to get that night out
of there get out of there and then hit
this night yes okay do this I think give
a check and then what I'm gonna play
back and then get this moving I want to
undermine the night oh this is a scary
position 14 black chop and then I just
want a pin stop just run a pin stuff oh
it's a little scary over there okay let
me get that c7 pon mine I can move with
check on I'm getting the rook be careful
be very careful okay actually what do we
have here bishop pair want to hang on
the bishop pair over here I'm on the
pine got the Pawnee oh no I'm in trouble
right
oh my goodness okay ed oh that one's
stung oh that wouldn't hurt man that one
is tough to stomach let me tell you Oh
my nights are gonna be homeless man that
one hurts so bad
man man what is going on okay I see that
is brutal you never want to fall for
that one to avoid that one at all costs
man here we go the night's gonna go
there you can't play right there I can't
deal with that I need to be flawless
this needs to be a flawless victory
right now grab a pond oh my king is dead
he's a dead man let's go here so I
thought I don't lose that pond with
check no keep it closed
oh my bishop was guarding that I didn't
realize okay let's uh I'll go for a
queen shade well they're not gonna go
for Queen trade though I gotta get out
of a pin or something it's just a sad
move to make they want to try I don't
want a dry one it's somehow in there
clock is ticking do they realize I moved
my king it's very scary over here Wow
just hanging in just hanging in my King
is walking a tightrope tightrope walker
pin keep them pinned there's a queen
check over here where it's nice and cozy
the room is still pin they're running
out of time right here
ha-ah the bishop wants to move look at
this there's no time look out for the
checks tricky checks tricky checks
tricky checks no time no time no time no
time for white they're out of time
back to tournament one 1800 160 no way
can I get second man it's falling down
you can't win them all
I need my pieces where are they Oh No
look at that slick my opponent was being
slick right there there's gonna be a
pawn push I should stop it before it
happens there take the pawn it's free
take the bait yes you took the bait
here we go run back home hit a bishop
push a pond
look for forks forks forks everywhere
forks forks grab this pawn giant pawn
center push get out of there bishop he's
off to the side he's not playing push
the F pawn push the D pawn push the e
pawn grab the Jeep on here we go
incoming the knight is gonna land on e6
check no it's not checked looking for me
I'm on the Queen I don't want to take
the Queen though looking for mates got
the Queen push up on give a check with
the bishop check with the bishop if the
knight moves oh I just want that night
to move my row could be taken but so
what oh that's me yeah it's back to
tournament back to chairmat 138 18140 to
138 five minutes and change could
somebody is that the guy that beat me I
think it was I had a rug and I only have
47
this is what you get this is what you
get in the horse mmm what am i doing
what am i doing g5
okay let's try g5 okay they're chewing
up a lot of time are they gonna push the
pond it's probably a good idea right
here right in the center open things up
here we go I gotta get that dark square
bishop and get this Knight to this
square that's the other reason I did
that okay let's go let's go let's go I
have enough on this now okay
g2 this pod could fall but I'm on g2
let's go here
g2 is on there's a bishop check if the
pawn pushes capture so I get the H file
I should have given a check first force
the King to a light square it's got to
be a killer right let's break down the
light squares Queen takes H I'm gonna
void the Queen exchange if that happens
off I'll throw in a check first Queen
takes pawn give a check queen of e8
let's come back here I guess this is a
weak point I might have to do a rook
lift here we go it's broken down here we
go open it up open it up open it up
let's do this I'm just gonna let the
knight hang out there for a little bit
open it up get rid of this Knight
ooo I mean why did I allow that okay
they're down on time back to termit 158
I'm in second 210 ah you can't catch 210
oh this is the guy that has two 1000
this is the guy that beat me but this is
an accelerated Queen's Indian or
something here we go you could do this
come on you just down a pond and the
times even it's bullet here we go
oh my peace is doing something shut down
this bishop get rid of the dark square
bishop get rid of that dark square
bishop oh man this is gonna be scary
take that guy back up dark squares now
get out of that my night where does it
want to be oh I know where wants to be
right here right here right here right
here right here
okay this is good this is good this is
good is it I have it no I don't come on
do something I'm on FX I should just
take no matter okay wait oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh that was a slick move right there
let's come over here oh just hit that
pond maybe
oh there's trades now ah there's checks
though it's the leading to mate check
discover checks no no no I didn't want
to do that
oh no no no no it can't be it can't be
just gonna take the night oh no mouse
lips everywhere I wanna cry just let me
cry
let me cry this one out I'm a dead man
I'm a dead man I'm cooked
you'll never suspect that how much time
they have didn't have any time check how
much time is left do I have this I got
the night how much time I don't have any
time stalemate
there's no time I'm tap is the winner he
deserves to win well done
killed my queen because of Mouse lip ah
man let me hold second who's this I'm
playing against Einstein now I gotta
play against Einstein just when you
think you can't get anywhere as you're
playing against Einstein now ah the most
lips are painful of Lloyd Mouse lips if
at all possible f5 you got to do it
f4o the night is gonna land them he's
gonna kill me he's gonna kill me in that
Bishop LightSquared Bishop is gonna have
a field day oh he's gonna have a field
day that Bishop oh you didn't want to
play there okay I can't deal with the
Queen right there I'm being attacked
right now I should take offense to that
so I don't want the knight or the bishop
to get to that square that's why I
pushed here we go 33 ticks no no trades
I'm on the night yes sneaky tricks
everywhere I'm on a rope no a truck
tonight oh you could do this too you
could still do it check oh they gotta be
scared
wrong Bishop that was a wrong Bishop
over here over here
give it check no they'll suspect that
one they'll never suspect this one
though yes oh thanks for playing what'd
I get
oh I didn't even get oh I got a t-shirt
no I clicked on the wrong thing
oh no confetti I went from second to
fourth place uh-oh what can you do the
Thunder Horace it's a killer man wow
that wipes me out man oh I got hit with
the t-shirt right there man
they're like here take a t-shirt and hit
the showers man clean yourself up
because that was a dirty game he played
right there dirty tournament uh-oh I
forgot to type good games
I clicked out of that did I do that on
purpose
maybe I did it on purpose maybe I didn't
want to say good games was I being a
poor sport there no I really did I
wanted to type in Gigi